[Music]
too much chris harrison getting
cancelled for what
so shout out to the goat the bachelor
ghost [ __ ] goat dog you're my
favorite
he's literally i laugh every time he
comes on screen it's amazing that's so
funny it's amazing he's so funny and
the idea that this guy could be
disrespectful there are 30
[ __ ] thirsty women in a [ __ ] hotel
they haven't seen the outside world
he he is famous to these women he can
take advantage of that oh he could be
sneaking in and out of hotels oh yeah
they'd be dying for that type of
attention
he doesn't do a single thing very nice
never offers career but hey i'll give
you better show promo if you do nothing
none of that nothing nothing takes
advantage of it nobody takes that check
is incredibly professional keeps it
moving me too no
okay no me too
he did something and i've thought a lot
about this
yeah he defended
one of the contestants so one of the
contestants i believe in in uh
rachel yeah looks like emily ratakowski
a little bit but more
broken
you [ __ ] up she's my favorite in the
house
oh really yeah she's my favorite to win
it really yeah yeah
she's my favorite 20. so she uh
went i think when she was in college to
like a old
south themed party sounds fun
so that's one of those tricky things
where if you're not white you're like
how do i dress like this is before
bridgerton you know what i mean where
you could just ignore racial history and
just dress the part anyway and
but an old south themed party
i was thinking about this and i was like
okay can we not have any
parties or festivities that are themed
in the past
while there are these incredibly like
racist atrocities happening
because they remind us of it you know
like it should
all of them be illegal right and i
and my first reaction was like that's
stupid there's more to the south than
just slavery
they had culture that was independent
from slavery
and they are reenacting this culture
they're not reenacting a slave
plantation they're reenacting
the outfits the dresses the drinks etc
right
so that was my knee-jerk reaction right
and then i thought hold on
i'm sure during nazi germany
there were outfits and dresses
and cultural um nuances
in the parties that that german people
could reenact
but if they did we'd be like yo
what what is this old german party going
on here i understand
the party might be separate from what's
happening
to jewish people in germany but it's
still reminiscent of that time
and it's hard to separate those two so
while i don't think that
a girl going to event like this
especially when they're [ __ ] 18 or 19
years old
they're in these like formative years of
their life well i don't think that
that's inherently racist
i do think it's something that you can
look back on as an adult
and go yeah that's a kind of stupid
thing to do
yeah that's because it is impossible to
separate that time with slavery
so that's a kind of stupid thing to do
even if that is not the intent
at all can i play devil's absence please
please please you're with your nazi
germany
yes parallel there was no german german
culture
didn't slap there's some southern [ __ ]
that's kind of fire son what do you mean
german culture didn't slap bruh
help me out i was trying
there's some fire south [ __ ] the accents
are fun the [ __ ]
everything is big big hair big dresses
it's all just kind of fun
now maybe it's not fun enough to
overcome the atrocity that people will
think of when they think of the south
but everything about germany in their
culture is just stupid the accent is
stupid you sound like [ __ ] idiots
you know what i mean your clothes it's
all we can think of with german clothes
is the actual ss
outfit that's a good point i can't we
can't think of any wardrobe we can think
of the uh
when they're giving you the beer
oh wait uh what's it called beer fest
october october
that's cool we go to october oh yeah
didn't that's not i think it's for the
girls and later housing
yeah yeah that's not in any way tied to
nazi germany as far as i know if that
was like
and if they dress like that we're cool
yeah because we're like oh that was
before you guys hated jews yes right yes
southern culture is a different in that
sense now maybe it's not enough
but i also think all chris harrison was
saying and he worded it poorly but
i saw that like two and a half minute
whatever yeah and he's basically
saying let's have some grace for this
girl she made a stupid mistake
now the one thing he [ __ ] up but he
can't it doesn't make any sense he go
he's like
he's the ladies interviewing he goes
well you have to ask yourself is it
stupid now in 2021
yes was it stupid in 2018 you got to
look at it from a different angle and
i'm like 2018 is not
it's not 1998. yeah yeah yeah so that
defense
dumb i think that he's a hundred percent
right about grace like
we have to give people grace yeah you
know especially when they're young and
impressionable and all their friends are
going to this party and like you said
there are some
really fun things i guess about southern
culture in terms like the dress etc you
know
if people want to dress like you know
marie antoinette
they want to dress like bridgerton like
i'm sure there's incredible atrocities
that are happening around the globe
because of the [ __ ] english empire oh
yeah but when they're celebrating those
outfits
they're not celebrating those atrocities
right right um
so it is tricky but grace yes you can't
immediately
put slavery and racism on a girl because
she goes to that party
yes right you can put i want to fit in
with my friends and i want to do things
with my friends
yes and i may be willing to do things
that like when i'm older i regret
and maybe i'm 18 i'm not i have no
worldly knowledge i probably grew up in
a suburb i don't understand
how much this can hurt people's feelings
i'm just going to a party in my mind
yeah
i'm 18. everyone at 18 is a [ __ ]
idiot you're not smart
i've yet to meet an 18 year old i'm like
yo i love the way you navigate the world
you get it you're wise
wisdom is for all people yes she's all
right it was stupid i guess
we wouldn't do it now she wouldn't do it
now she was 18.
i think i can forgive that so here's the
thing
chris harrison says it what al nah i
don't know i just
and maybe it's because i'm black i just
can't that's why you're opening
south without connecting slavery and
that's valid
and that i cannot argue it like even
while you're dressing up it's like you
still
have slavery i was making that argument
and i knew it wasn't the strongest so
even if you say that i will i'll be all
right fair enough
i can't accept i think sorry to
interrupt but i think as northerners
our only understanding of the south is
slavery
okay and now it's transitioned into
racism or bigotry so i think most
northerners or even like california's
so that's what they assume the south is
like whenever they
northerners want to do a dumb person
accent what do they do
southern southern next whenever they
want to do a racist accent
southern accent so that's our own
bigotry towards people from the south
and it's because when we learn about the
south we often don't go there
most northerners aren't going to visit
in [ __ ] mississippi
right they're not visiting alabama you
know
so we don't know anything but what we've
read in the books and what we learned
about
so it's hard for us to disconnect their
history
from and their culture from slavery
because we think they're one and the
same
when there were i imagine plenty of
people
that did not have slaves but were still
southern culturally you know like the
one group that seems to get away from
this
is uh like people from new orleans yeah
like people from new orleans can still
like maintain their
yeah their own kind of like unique
culture they can wear
cool outfits and do all this kind of
stuff and we kind of just gone
oh yeah but uh that's a new orleans
thing yeah if you do that in alabama
or mississippi we're like that that's
kind of slavy
like what you say you said what i mean
but like for whatever reason new orleans
is forgiven yeah i don't know the exact
timeline but it just feels like uh
new orleans had like they it's more they
mixed a little bit i don't know earlier
so that's why it doesn't like
creole culture is mixed like black
creole yeah that is a good point
they are mixed more mixed culturally
yeah it almost feels like the white
people down there have a lot of like
black
influence and like almost like a like
like french or haitian
influence like yeah it just seems super
mixed so maybe it takes a little
stank of the racism off um that's
possible but they had slaves throughout
the civil war
even after the emancipation proclamation
they didn't stop slavery until 1865.
i'm pretty sure yeah so it's like
oh no it's tricky but chris harrison
took a leave of absence from the show
for this
because he was i don't know he was what
the [ __ ] i'm deaf or something
i don't again even what i'm saying out
like when i was saying that i was trying
to kind of be funny but
if we oh if we say okay fine you cannot
uh
separate the old south from slavery can
you at least
understand why someone would say okay a
girl made a dumb mistake let's just try
to be a little graceful
oh yeah that's what we're saying but i
think you could still call it like oh
this was a dumb thing it was
sure yeah i'll accept that i'll give you
that both are true
both are true like like we've all done
things we regret
as kids you know whether it was like
tease people whether it was like
you know some joining [ __ ] gangs and
[ __ ] like that like we've all been a
part of things we wish we didn't do
right when we were young and now that
we're older we're like [ __ ] that was
dumb and like maybe i affected people in
a wrong way
you know like i should have done that
absolutely but we're allowed to be
forgiven
you know i think that we forgive people
i mean we forgive rappers for way more
yeah i mean like
rappers openly rapping about
harming people yeah and i love it not
only harming people
selling drugs and harming people within
their own community yeah we have some of
the biggest black lives matter supporter
rappers
who proved to us earlier in their
careers
that black lives did not really matter
to them
if you listen to those early albums
they're not talking about
white people that they're celebrating
that's rewarded in a way that people are
going to get upset at it but
what you're saying is this is right it's
they put
capitalism over the lives in their own
community if they needed to or
my survival and thriving and then we saw
them change and become people that like
we admire and we look up to
and like lead us yeah in terms of
civil rights and black life mattering
we look at them and go holy [ __ ] this
person is putting his money where his
mouth is
i'm [ __ ] with that person that person
is real he's matured
so if we can let somebody who's
committed the most egregious acts
possible or at least has said that he
committed those acts or tried to commit
those acts
right to humans i think that we could
offer a little grace to a girl who goes
to a [ __ ] stupid themed party
yeah yeah right i could definitely agree
with that and maybe if we start
letting it maybe if we start allowing
people to like go i [ __ ] up as a kid
right maybe maybe we just leave that
open a little bit more
there'll be much more people who admit
it yeah there'll be people who come out
there's like man
how stupid were those parties we would
throw we're all full of [ __ ] that's all
we need to accept
all of us ain't [ __ ] and that's it